hey what's up guys welcome back to my
channel on this video i'm going to be
interviewing a guy called sam gallagher
who has built up a rent to rent hmo
portfolio in bolton just outside of
manchester he's financially independent
he's done super super well and in this
video in this interview he's going to be
explaining and breaking down exactly how
he did it the perseverance he had to go
through some of the setbacks but how
much money he's making and ultimately
how you can do the same thing too as a
property entrepreneur starting with xero
so if you enjoy my channel please do me
a massive favor hit the like button that
way the youtube algorithm will pick the
video up and it will go around and
impact and help more people but sam
thank you so much for coming on the show
no problem thanks for having me so how
old are you sam 27 27 years old and
what's your background before you got
into property like what what were you
doing uh so i basically always had like
the nine to five job um just your
standard jobs like warehouse jobs i
worked at mcdonald's when i was younger
um i've worked at bolton hospital as a
and that job was quite quite good really
yeah because he was helping people out
especially during colvin it's amazing
because back in the day like before we
were alive probably people used to have
one job for life and that was it exactly
whereas now the average person by age
40s have like 20 different jobs and job
security is really a thing of the past i
think i fully agree with you i think i
think it's crazy um you hear about
people all the time
constantly changing jobs constantly
looking for different jobs not happy in
the job and i think that's like
a really old school mentality i think
times have changed nowadays
what was it what was the reason that
wanted you to get into property i've
always been that person where
i've always wanted to work for myself
i'd never want to work for anybody else
i don't like having a boss having to
answer to a boss yeah and i was always
looking for that way out of the nine to
five life the old school mentality
and i discovered robert kiyosaki's book
like a lot of people do and that's what
initially sparked that interesting
property so that book's rich dad poor
dad which obviously
everybody needs to read it's an
incredible that's kind of what got me
started you know robert kiyosaki's book
and um so you read that book and then
what happened it was everything real it
was like the motivation from it it was
the interest in it it was that vision
that
there is a way out of your nine-to-five
job
there is that prospect of financial
freedom yes
so how much did you spend on training
i spent
just over 23 grand
on training
hell of all i wanna that's a lot of
money a lot nothing wrong with that
but
it's like
you've got to see a return on investment
when you're investing in training you've
got to make sure that every time you
spend a pound you're getting two pound
back you're gonna get supported and
stuff now again we're not gonna go too
deep into the training what happened
because that's kind of irrelevant but
when we met
where were you at and what were you kind
of because you were like the most
upset angry skeptical i'm done with this
[ __ ] you know because you've gone on the
train and let's face it you haven't done
any deals yep you know so so
firstly why was that and what do you
think kind of happened because i want
people to really learn from this and i
don't want to shy away from the bad
because i'm a massive believer in
self-education and going on training and
educating yourself and investing in
yourself but at the same time i don't
want to shy away from the fact that for
you it didn't work out yeah on this
occasion and of course we know that
there's a success in the end and
it's not all bad but i just wanted to
really be real and authentic and just
break down like what happened and why do
you feel it didn't work out for you in
the way that maybe you hoped you would
yeah i mean
firstly
me as a person i i always tell the truth
i'm always trying to be authentic
um so before anything i just want people
to know that
um but i think it is important you've
got to have the training 100
even though the initial training i would
say is not the best what i had what i
paid for wasn't the best
but i can see how you do need to be
trained it is important to have somebody
as well who's
been there
done where you want what you want to do
and get where you want to be yeah
and i think it's like i say very
important to have that training yes and
that initial training like i say wasn't
the best
which
i i come off that but i didn't want to
give up yeah
now i'm this person that will just keep
going and going and going and going and
going until i succeed
i'm just that type of person so i had to
find
another way
of finding the right training finding a
way to make it succeed
which then i discovered you
and so obviously
even though i was skeptical
the reason for that obviously i'd spent
all that money and got absolutely
nowhere
i said to myself the next decision i
make has to be the right decision
i need to be confident in what i do next
is gonna succeed yes what why did you
not at that point just say that's it i'm
doing it without training i don't need a
mentor i don't need any support i'm just
gonna do it why did you still feel the
need to have a mentor because when you
came to me i know you said you know you
wanted support you wanted mentoring you
were really you felt like you've been
burned so you're very skeptical but why
did you feel the need to have support
and training moving forward
i think it was that thing like that i
knew i knew training was important i
knew mentoring was important to get
where you want to be yeah um because if
you don't have that
god knows how long it's going to take
you could never succeed yes um so it was
a more mere fact of
i i'd done the training that was bad
but i knew i had to have training
so that's when obviously like i
discovered you yeah and knew then
i needed the right training the right
mentoring in order to succeed yeah okay
so when you went through the deal
finding extravaganza and it was all
online because this was during lockdown
it was so so you know all of this was
online so you did the deal finding
extravaganza online yeah which also
included mentoring and support um so
what happened and how did your first
deal come and what was your first deal
and what was the process and you know we
want to know the story and the
nitty-gritty of how you achieve what
you've achieved
so obviously with that like you say it
was all online which was awesome because
it eliminated the little things around
it like the travel time say to a course
any accommodation that you have to stay
at like if you've traveled away and so
firstly with it being online you could
do it at home which was awesome but what
i loved about it was there was so many
little tips tricks how to's
which i picked up from that
which wasn't in the other training right
but the beauty of it obviously it came
along with that that mentoring as well
and um i think that was the important
first step
to me getting my first deal yeah and
because it it reignited that fire it
gave me that spark again it gave me that
light at the end of the tunnel that it
can work yeah
even though i've had the bad experience
with the training you know what yeah it
can work you can succeed in property
yeah and i think that that was like the
beauty of the dfe and the mentorship and
and your first deal how soon after you
had finished the training and and stuff
did you get your first deal in bolton uh
so it did take me a little bit of time
after that um i think it took me a good
roughly about 10 months i think it's a
long time bro but but
i would say it's not through the dfe or
anything to do with the training
it was literally i'd got that spark from
the training
initially went on the dfe online and the
mentoring
but
life coming the way what happened
well
it was
basically a life situation with a
relationship that it started off where
it was a fairy tale
so
soon as i got with this particular
partner
who we won't name here we won't name
um it was like one of them where
it was a fairy tale right but as we all
know
fairy tales don't last love is blind
yeah and she didn't like your property
business no she didn't like the idea of
doing property she thought you were
gonna get ripped off yeah um and and i
think having a partner even though
you're in love and she might have been
amazing in some ways having a partner
that's not for your business and for
your success is one of the hardest
things when you're trying to be
successful 100 100
um it quickly
in the first couple of months it was
that fairy tale you i was on top of the
world i thought perfect perfect
relationship i'm building i'm starting
to build my business on the way to my
first deal
quickly took a turn spiraled out of
control
and it got to the point in the end
unfortunately where
she cheated on me
and
it didn't stop there for me as a person
i went down another level i ended up
again i'm truthful honest i ended up
depressed at the doctors
on depression tablets but the key thing
which i will say to everybody
whoever you are don't ever give up no
matter how bad the situation is
don't ever give up no matter what what
happens geez man so you spent 23 grand
on some training
didn't quite work out not to say that it
was their fault and they were terrible
no you just didn't gel with it for
whatever reason
didn't work out then you came on the
deal finding extravaganza with me and i
remember being like we're gonna have to
make this guy successful yeah i was
determined man and and and not just me
but the whole team we were like come on
sam we're gonna make this work and then
you've got this
whiny ass girlfriend
yeah who then cheats on you breaks your
heart and leaves you on depression
tablets yeah we're like damn
i mean that was heading for an interview
on losers on a tuesday
like that was rough so that was writing
yeah so that was and that was when how
long ago like a year ago now uh so that
would be march time next year last year
sorry it started that spiral in march
last year and by may
that that was it i was down i was over
so 10 months ago you were like a failed
property entrepreneur broken-hearted on
depression not just no money but also
massively in the red
working as a porter at the hospital at
bolton hospital boston hospital so how
do you go from that low
to then now financially independent
multiple properties and i know to you
you might say like oh i'm not where i
want to be but you're making how much
how much profit are you making
at the moment just from you just from
your first two rent events how much
profit you're making so from the first
two making 1.6 k 1.6 k and and that's
all coming in systemized you've got a
third one you've got a fourth one that's
going through at the moment so you now
have you quit your job quit my job last
year 17th for november smashed it so now
things have took a massive turn and
you're on top of the world on top of the
world right more than i've ever been so
this is why i wanted you on the show so
much because i wanted to get from if
there's anyone that's in that place
where they're maybe on depression or
they maybe have tried and failed and
they're in the gutter they're in the
valley
how do you get from the valley to the
mountain top
i think it's a combination of a few
things um
number one family support
and number two supporting the community
like you said
you guys was there you was spurring me
on no matter what
and number three
i think always
never give up with the idea of property
so no matter how low you are
do something to do with property whether
you go to a networking event whether
you're just watching a youtube video on
property every now and then yeah just
something to do with property so that
you you it's always there in the back of
your mind
you've never given up on it right
and i think as long as you've got
something from that mix of of ideas
you will end up pulling yourself back
eventually that's great advice sam and
also
as well you've got to put things into
perspective i think because people think
you can go on a training program or
watch some youtube videos and then
within you know three weeks become a
millionaire and live happily ever after
but that's not that's not reality and
everyone works at different speeds but
if you think about if you want to be a
doctor or a lawyer or anything you go to
uni for four or five years just to get
the qualification then you go and get
the job work your way up it takes years
and in property it can also take years
yeah you know and as i say some people
can become financially free in three
months if you're samuel leeds
you know fine but i've got i've got 12
13 years experience but when you're
starting out from scratch and you've got
you've got a girlfriend that's that's
personal issues and debts and all kinds
of stuff
you've got to look at the long game and
that's what you did even when you were
in the valley you thought you know what
this is still possible i'm going to keep
getting back on the horse and you
continued um you know sort of you're
obviously being mentored and you
continued paying that and you continued
investing in yourself even though you
were in a really bad situation so that
first deal how did you find that first
deal how did that come about because
that presumably that was the moment when
you're like oh my goodness this is real
yeah yeah i mean it came about for a
combination of obviously the training
with with you
and the mentorship from you and your
team
and because obviously i had a bit of
mentoring like when it was online with
the calls and stuff yeah my mom and yeah
yeah yeah so
putting all that together as what you
would say is one package
that's what initially allowed me to get
that first deal yeah i had the right
what you would say sort of team in place
if you want to call it that
um
and it was just then through having
persistence of coming out on the other
side
it was almost like i was starting afresh
because i'd got over the depression
and then i was obviously starting to
implement properly yes i had the time to
implement everything properly and
finally gain that traction yeah whereas
obviously like i said previously
as well as yes some of the training was
okay and and it was what i needed
that life stuff
was bogging it down all the time
so he was gaining that little bit of
traction but the life stuff would smack
it back down again yeah so where did you
find your first deal i want to know was
it an agent was it a landlord how did
you find it funnily enough it was an
agent okay in bolton in bolton big agent
small agent
independent agent really um they're not
a massive chain throughout the country
yeah um they've got a few branches
dotted around the north west yeah
they're not by any means like i say a
big chain agent why is that important
that's i feel i've always felt since i
started
learning and getting the deals that
it's the independent agents you want to
start a target you get the big chain
agents and they just don't want to know
so for instance uh if they're
country-wide dixons these types of large
agents that have got you know nationwide
presence sometimes when you're going and
you're trying to do something a little
bit creative
they've got employees they've got
systems red tape and they're interested
whereas if you go to the smaller
independent agents because you might be
speaking to the owner or the manager
it's family run you can be a bit more
creative and do things like renting
rents yeah yeah and the the they're a
lot more open to it yeah
they're a lot more open to the different
creative strategies like rent to rent
whereas like i say when you speak to the
big chain agents
they're just like straight away no so so
did you call did you go in
i actually uh went in that's something
then i had a viewing with him on a hmo
okay that's where it came about huge
advice there though
small independent agents and just go in
in person so when you went in what did
you say i was just confident it was it
was all about that confidence
and it the best advice i can give
they're just other people
did just other people just go in there
have a conversation like we are now yeah
just be natural um
one thing i would say
don't mention rent to rent yeah just
mention company lap right
and just have that conversation
so be honest so so you went in and you
had a chat and you said i'm a small new
company and i'm looking for um a
landlord who might be tired where i can
do a company that
and i said oh well we've got a property
so they took you around this property
and and what was it
uh so it was actually a five bed right
it was already set up as a hmo and it
had just become vacant it had had
contractors in there a set of
contractors that had done work on a lidl
in the area okay um and obviously
no it was vacant
the landlord was more open to again
having that
long term guaranteed rental income
because obviously while the contractors
have been building this little they've
been in there for a long time so the
landlord then i'm presuming was used to
having that guaranteed income right not
as much tenant changeover yes so when
obviously we approached with our model
the rent to rent model which is a
guaranteed rent
um a long term tenancy
so how much rent did you offer to pay
we offered to pay 950 a month 950 pounds
five bit hmo who's paying the bills
we're paying all the bills so you're
paying the bills you're paying
everything so you're committing to
probably more like 13 14 hundred pounds
a month yeah i think we
will with guaranteed rent and bills
we're paying
about 1500 1500. was that scary signing
a contract to say that you're going to
commit to paying 1500 yeah it was scary
it was scary because i was thinking
things like what happens if i don't fill
it right i'm then liable to pay all
these costs yeah so it was really really
scary but
i had to tell myself
it works yeah
the systems work
just go for it right and
i'll tell you what one key thing
you'll remember this that i've heard you
say before
walk the abc
worry about xyz later yeah and that was
what did it for me so i just i just did
it right and i think as well you had the
right training support you had enough
mentoring to be able to get people to
overlook the deal you knew how to do due
diligence
signed it which is massive respect yeah
and then did you have to pay like a
deposit and stuff and upfront rent yes
so we're paid one month's deposit one
month's rent where did you get that
money from
a family friend as an investor right so
again when i was initially taking this
deal on
it was one of them i have none of my own
money where am i gonna how am i gonna
finance this deal where am i gonna get
the money from yeah um but again i was
always taught you don't know who's got
money in the bank
so it was it was just a matter of
thinking of people around me yeah you
might have money in the bank yeah you
might not but just ask the question
and lo and behold i asked the question
and it was like yeah no problem i'll
give you the money how much money did
you need to set it up because obviously
a couple of grand just for the deposit
in the rent yeah so we
i actually lent 5000 of the family
friend
and that was enough to cover
first month's rent first month's deposit
and what was speculated for the light
refurb of painting and furnishing yeah
and you agreed to pay them back 10
interest a year 10 over the year right
and do they want their money back now
they don't actually it's been a year
though funnily enough uh they drew the
the money back with the interest in july
but i had the conversation today with
the same investor um
about rolling his money over to the next
year right we'll pay his interest in
july but roll the five grand over for
another temperature right and meanwhile
on his money that you borrowed you're
making obviously really good money so
it's making when you can make money on
other people's money that's when you can
really create a lot of wealth
on a big or a small scale so okay so
you've got this property 950 a month to
the landlord how much are you renting
the whole property out for we rent a
we've got one room which is a really
large attic room so we actually we
charge a little bit more for that than
the other rooms so for the four standard
rooms we charge 400 a month yeah all
bills included and the large attic room
will charge 500 a month so it's 2 100
yeah
so you're making about 600 quid a month
on that
we're making yeah just over that just
over 600 pound a month okay so you've
got that property which is giving you
600 pound amount of profit obviously you
need to pay your investor but you only
need to pay your investor 500 pounds a
year yeah so
you're doing pretty okay with that so
that's a nice little property which
you're controlling what was your second
property second property was a large six
bed hmo and again it was already set up
as a hmo yeah so it was just a matter of
what you would say the light refurb
which is obviously painting furnishing
and the other little bit of a job yes
but again we lent the money for that
offering investor so again
none of my own money went into it yeah
um quickly we got a turnaround on that
um
it was a little bit quicker
than the first one only because we'd
learnt
like lessons from the first one so we've
got painters to paint the second one
where i painted the first one myself
yeah um
no i know obviously like initially you
might need to do stuff like that
yourself
but you quickly want to get out of that
of course
how much does that how much profit does
that one make uh so our second one makes
just over a thousand pound so that's
where the 1.6 k comes absolutely
so it's even more profitable what about
the third one what's the profit profit
expectations on that so the third one uh
it's actually due to be fully completed
ready to tenant this week at the end of
this week sorry um but this one is
hopefully like figures wise we've
speculated to profit
just over 800 pound a month nice so all
in all then you're gonna be way above
two thousand pound a month and then what
happened today
we got another offer accepted
fourth deal
and this one is an incredible deal how
much profit you think in a month this
one's gonna profit thousand and eighty
eight pound a month incredible on a five
bed
absolutely ensuite and is that all in
bolton all in bolton absolutely
brilliant what has your experience been
with the actual management of the
properties has it been a headache has it
been a nightmare have there been times
when the rooms are sticking and you
can't rent them out no to be honest to
be honest no with the right again i know
i know you hear all the time with the
right training the right mentoring but
seriously with the right training the
right mentoring
as long as you implement that stuff
correctly
we've we've not really had fingers
crossed
we've not really had many major tenant
issues um our major property issues and
we've always managed to fill the rooms
very very quickly so our first one we
filled it in 21 days
um and the second one was filled in ten
days absolutely brilliant um also there
was a point where you put it on service
accommodation we did so tell me about
that and why did you do that and what
happened uh so it was that thing that in
the back of my mind even though i knew
the training was correct and the
mentoring was correct
i need to get this money in quickly i
don't want these rooms to be empty
so with the first property deal that i
got
um
i picked up this little tip from
somewhere i can't remember where it was
but
while you're trying to get your tenants
in there as a hmo
bang all rooms on airbnb booking.com and
rent them out on a nightly basis as a
service accommodation
oh my god i never thought bolton would
be like this but every single weekend we
had them rooms full
was getting bookings during the week and
we got to the point where i was getting
too many bookings and not enough rooms
available wow it was crazy so again it's
like you've got a strategy toolbox where
you've got serviced accommodation rent
them on short stays hmos
longer term and and you've just adapted
you found your area why did you pick
bolton as your area it was just one of
the things that i live in the area yeah
um so
initial
once you've done your training and your
mentoring
obviously when you come to pick in your
area and assess in your area it just
made sense to
i live in bolton let's assess that first
because that's what the deal finding
extravaganza is about a lot isn't it's a
lot about you choosing your patch what
advice would you give to somebody that's
maybe not in bolton because sometimes
what i've noticed sam is people think oh
you're in bolton therefore bolton's the
magic area and and people are traveling
up from you know milton keynes and all
over the place to come to bolton and
it's like well actually no
you know it's there's not one magic area
but what advice would you give to
somebody following from the deal finally
extravaganza does wanting to find their
patch what would you
what tips would you say i would just say
start where you live
analyze that area you don't need to be
traveling an hour two hours outside your
area just because you've you've heard me
say
bulletin works yeah or liverpool works
you don't need to travel hours and hours
yep
start with your own area
analyze that
properly
with the training that you've learned
and then branch out slowly into the
surrounding areas if that area doesn't
work where you live right but
from my experience i would say 90 of
areas do work
in like the country yeah i guess it also
depends on what strategy is if you're
wanting to do hmos yeah and you're in a
field in wales and the nearest
supermarket's 45 minutes away it might
be that that isn't the right strategy
yeah but it might be that service
accommodation could work because there's
lots of walks and things around so it's
about
thinking what strategies are going to
work best in my area yeah what's my
what's my goal here what am i trying to
create and really getting i think it's
so important to have a strategy and an
area before you start randomly buying
deals all over the place from deal
sources you need to really have a
business plan and a strategy yeah um so
what's been what would you say has been
the challenging part of the journey
obviously take it aside
spending 23 grand on training and
feeling like it didn't work and getting
your heart broken and someone cheated on
you from a property perspective not not
so much personal what's been the hardest
bit i would probably say
always always remember to
not get bogged down with looking 10
steps ahead yeah literally take it one
step at a time yeah literally take that
phrase what i learned from you walk the
abc worry about the xyz later yeah
implement that with every single thing
you do yeah because a lot of people they
look 10 steps ahead yeah and it becomes
that thing of
analysis paralysis right they don't move
forward yeah so trust in what you've
learned trust in what you've been told
trust that it works and take it one step
at a time i would say
for me
it was
that that was the hardest thing just
keep telling that to myself in the back
of my mind yeah incredible and what
would be your advice to someone starting
out that's maybe starting in zero maybe
in a bad place that's wanting to do rent
to rent that's wanting to become
financially independent and leave their
job what will be your best piece of
advice
best piece of advice i would say
would probably be
never give up yeah never give up yeah
even even if you don't
take training right now
you and you take it six months down the
line
my best piece of advice would be
never ever
ever no matter what happens in your life
give up
great advice however bad it is yeah
whatever situation you're in
just never give up and right now we're
sat in this little room not at my house
yeah because we're preparing for wha
why are we here the crash course
tomorrow baby yeah the craziest one
wow first crash course in person yeah
obviously even though i've got the deals
knowing i'm on top of the world the
important thing for me as well is this
is number one for me i do have a new
partner now oh i have a new partner
called bethany right and
she's so supportive she's always telling
me how proud she is of me but always
know
this is number one for me as bad as some
people might think it might be
my business is obviously has to be
number one for me
um
talk to me more about that why does your
business have to be number one and how
does your partner feel about that
it's just because of obviously like the
past where
i've obviously i've been through two
relationships which didn't which didn't
work i got cheated on but it was that
thing that i've never give up on
property yeah and and this is now
where i've become successful and it's
made me happy as a person right so no
matter what's around me any
relationships anything this has to be
number one
and when i went into the new
relationship
i had to make it clear to her that
that's how i am as a person now and she
totally understood it and like i say
she's always now
supporting me telling me how approaches
of me
and how much she wants me to do well
anything i need she helps even like
cleaning the hmos
wow
how much nicer must it feel to be not
only financially free but to have a
partner that loves and supports you
it's so nice it's so nice
i'm so pleased well on that note
congratulations guys if you've been
inspired listening to this interview if
you've been motivated if you've picked
up golden nuggets why don't you go ahead
drop a comment in below shout out some
love towards sam and also hit the like
and subscribe for more videos if you
want to watch more interviews like this
where i interview some of our students
that have become financially independent
through property guess what i've been
doing interviews every single week for
an entire three years and you can see
over 100 interviews right up here if you
want to come down to the property
investors crash course then i'm going to
leave a link in the description where
you can get booked on for free limited
tickets available and also subscribe
over here thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time
[Music]